[Musique]
les allemands étaient chez moi on m'a
dit
résigne toi mais je n'ai pas si
et j'ai repris mon arme
le vent souffle sur les tombes
laliberté reviendra on nous oubliera
[Musique]
nous rentrerons dollon
en fait je m'ennuyais un petit peu
j'attendais qu'il arrive quelque chose
en classe gt asséché lutteuse et la vie
était un peu à la fois compliqué parce
que je me faisais attraper des deux
côtés et puis en même temps je trouvais
qu'elle manquait de piquant et carragher
s'est déclaré et bien j'étais assez
contente et j'ai dit à ma grand-mère en
fin de vie va changer
il était très fâché parce qu'elle avait
14 ans avec mais pour moi la guerre
c'était c'était une grande aventure
héroïque avant d'être autre chose je
sais pas pourquoi je pense qu on nous
enseignait l'histoire pas du tout comme
aujourd'hui on nous enseigne et des
grands événements où la france était une
nation merveilleuse on nous parlait des
grands hommes moi j'ai adoré
vercingétorix du déclin et d'autre et je
pense qu'on s'identifie à ses héros
nous devions nous marier en septembre 39
et tout était en train de se préparer
dans notre maison familiale à la
campagne quand je lève est arrivé le
soir en disant qu' il fallait absolument
que notre mariage
les lieux immédiatement le soir même car
ils étaient mobilisés avant la
mobilisation générale et en tant que
fils active ils étaient mobilisés plus
parce que la situation internationale
était très grave
et puis un moment donné nous étions dans
la rue tous les deux et nous avons vu
arriver vers nous à un des camarades
qu'elle un visage bouleversé très grave
et qu'il nous a dit c'est la guerre ça a
été
j'étais d'une nouvelle tragique c'était
la foudre qui tombait sur new ça voulait
dire aussi pour nous la séparation
j'ai vu partir non mariés avec des
attitudes parce que je me disais qu'une
guerre se met jamais cours et je me
demandais pourquoi l'intention c'est
parti
on
e
c'était notre principal sujet de
conversation
c'était le mari les leurs qui
partiraient trop loin du jeu jour leur
masse ça pouvait arriver et le miel qui
était déjà loin et les jeunes femmes de
militaires dont elle était dans le même
cas que moi allons se réunissent et ont
amené nos enfants ensemble
on menait une vie très calme très calme
et puis tout à coup le mois de mai est
arrivé et à ce moment là nous avons
commencé à voir arriver les réfugiés de
belgique puis du nord de la france et
ensuite de plus en plus près de loup et
un moment donné les gens du village sont
venus trouver ben mes beaux parents pour
leur dire que vous ne pouvez pas rester
il faut partir et vous ne décidez de
partir tous ensemble
[Musique]
avec des troupes françaises qui montait
- type descender avec ma petite fille
les nounous en voiture et on vaut vous
raconter des choses épouvantables qu'il
fallait pas s'arrêter qui avait des
parts à jus tice qui demandait qu'on
aime qu'on les amène étaient des espions
si blague ça a fait un voyage très
difficile dans cette foule dont nous
faisions partie il y a eu de tout cas
des avions allemands qui ont survolé un
moment et moi je me suis dit tout de
suite j'ai vu la programmer sur leur
ventre me suis dit ils ne vont pas tirer
nous sommes de pauvres gens complètement
sans armes
évidemment ils vont pas tirer mais au
contraire ils ont tiré
[Musique]
se retrouver dans un fossé mon grand
père s'était couché sur moi pour
protéger nous n'avions rien mais autour
il y avait beaucoup de sang et j'ai pu
dire bon ça va pas être marrant ça a
commencé comme ça
[Musique]
non la première claque que j'ai prise
c'est quand je suis allé recevoir les
réfugiés où j'étais je faisais partie du
scoutisme on a demandé plus coûteuse
recevoir les réfugiés
et moi je suis partie à chanter en
laissant mes camarades sur leurs devoirs
et j'ai été très choqué de voir ces gens
malheureux ces gens qui tout d'un coup
la détresse la misère le tout le cortège
qui suit la guerre ça m'a sauté aux yeux
on leur servait une soupe dont j'aurais
pas voulu et on se penchait sur leur
malheur on était très gentil sans se
douter qu'une semaine après c'était nous
qui allions partir sur la route
les troupes allemandes descendait vers
le sud par la route nord-sud qui passait
le long de du jardin et chaque fois que
c'est commun de de l'armée allemande
commencé à apparaître et sûrement à
s'arrêter parce que nous avions une
grille sur la route
ma mère était très très violemment
opposé à tout ce qui passait enfin la
première chose qu'elle faisait c'était
de fermer les volets ensuite 2 2
[Musique]
e
toute cette armée qui déboulait vers le
sud montrait sa force sa puissance il y
avait vraiment une affirmation de la
force
imaginez d'ailleurs leur état d'esprit
dit et quelque chose même pour eux
probablement de complètement inattendu
ça a été vraiment l'horreur sans savoir
exactement sur quelle forme une année je
concrétise est le plus terrible c est l
annonce de l'armistice je crois
franchement que mon enfance s'est
terminée ce jour là mon grand père qui
était un homme assez terrible on
l'appelait entre nous l'empereur il
était impressionnant s'est écroulé en
sanglots mais épouvantable alors ça nous
a beaucoup impressionné en plus la
france qui était invincible puisque mon
père mon grand père avait été invaincue
la france 2 14
la voilà qui pliait le genou devant iter
[Musique]
alors quand ça a été la justice society
la consternation la concertation nous
étions tous effondrés pour nous c'était
la fin d'un monde et c'était réellement
la fin d'un monde
ça a été jamais plus on a revu ces
devises comme avec lui avant ça ça a été
très très et ans jeune mère de famille
vous ressenti ce encore plus qu'une
jeune fille on était d'ailleurs on avait
lutté en espagne pour les anciens
d'espagne c'est tout naturellement que
je me suis retrouvé mois dès mon retour
à paris c'était donc le 15 juillet quand
j'y suis retourné à perdre
c'était décidé de faire quelque chose de
lutter pour contre contre des allemands
contre l'occupation et que je
recherchais quand je suis arrivé à ivry
où j'habitais que j'ai essayé de
retrouver par exemple des membres des
membres du parti mais y'avait pas
d'adultes qui avait pas d'adultes et
aviles et un million cinq cent mille de
prisonniers
[Musique]
où
dans toutes les familles c'était
l'angoissé choix dans d'autres cas hors
de moi de ne pas savoir si joseph était
mort ou vivant et partir du moment où on
savait qu il était vivant c'était déjà
un soulagement alors j'ai fini par le
retrouver à saint dizier et s'ils sont
les habitants de la ville qui m'ont dit
que les prisonniers étaient enfermés
dans un collège
le lendemain je suis revenue j'ai appris
que nie que les prisonniers étaient
partis prochain gta chou et la
les conditions étaient très différentes
parce qu'ils étaient enfermés très
nombreux
alors j'ai crié son nom j'ai entendu
qu'on ne répercutaient de deux casernes
ont caserne
et puis je les vues sur vire notre côté
de la grille et là j'ai traversé la
route en dépit des des sentinelles nous
sommes touchés la main travers la grille
c'était la dernière fois que j'ai vu
nous croyons
que l'honneur des français
il a continué la guerre et de leurs
alliés
quelqu'un nous a dit vous savez de
londres sur la bbc on entend un général
français et un soir on a entendu de
gauche qui parlait et en fait ils
disaient exactement ce qu'on avait envie
d'entendre
et on s'est dit bon eh ben on est devenu
de ce jour des gaullistes enthousiaste
si vous voulez on a on s'est accroché à
de gaulle comme on serait accroché mais
je pense que même s'il n'y avait pas eu
de gaulle on aurait fait quelque chose
mais disons plein du moment qu'ils
étaient là on sait tout de suite
accroché à lui et on a essayé tout de
suite de trouver alors dont on parlait
si vous voulez et c'est comme ça que
dans la suite on a pu faire de la
résistance et mon mari rentre et était
entré à ce moment là alors on s'est dit
il faut se rendre à l'appel du général
de gaulle et nous sommes allés à vichy
pour essayer d'avoir des papiers parce
qu'il y avait encore point liens de
partir en angleterre assez facilement à
l'époque
et là il a rencontré un officier du 2e
bureau qui lui a dit mais non vous serez
beaucoup plus utile en rentrant chez
vous et en organisant une résistance
chez vous et quand nous nous sommes
retrouvés pour déjeuner j'ai dit allons
nous partons en angleterre et mon mari a
dit nous retournons chez nous et j'ai
été mais consterné
vous ne pouvez pas vous imaginer je me
suis dit retourner subir l'occupation
allemande
pour moi ç'a semblé quelque chose dépôt
vente
[Musique]
c'était la nuit il y avait plus de gars
il ya eu plus de ville tout était en
ruines il y avait ces soldats étrangers
qui étaient peut-être pas plus méchant
que d'autres mais qui parlait pas ma
langue et puis qui étaient là et j'ai
voulu sur le conseil d'une personne qui
était là à les trouver la croix rouge
pour avoir un brancard pour mon grand
père et j'ai dû traverser cette ce
rassemblement de soldats et en jambes et
leurs corps de dormir sur leurs sacs et
naturellement ils ont fait comme tous
les soldats du monde et ont voulu
s'amuser avec cette petite jeune fille
qui avait jupe à fleurs elle est sur le
dos et on ne dit pas qu'ils ont voulu
faire plus mais moi j'ai eu peur et un
officier a mis fin cette scène de la
façon la plus plus déplorable qu'ils
soient en main m'afflige en un magistral
coup de pied au derrière qui m'a envoyé
les bras en croix par terre et il ya à
ce moment précis sous les faits n'ont
pas de douleur mais de l'humiliation
ce qui est plus bien putté je me suis
dit bon je sais qu'il y en a qui
résistent à l'intérieur je vais les
trouver je vais moi aussi me battre
[Musique]
quand on voit des gens occupés tout
notre pays c'est quelque chose de
terrible hein de voir ces gens qui
s'installent qui sont comme chez eux et
nous qui n'avons plus le droit de rien
faire c'était alors c'était quelque
chose d'aussi encore plus pénible c'est
lorsque nous sommes revenus à paris
qu'on a vu tous les étendards allemand
dans la rue de rivoli dans sur toute la
place de la concorde en venant de la
gare et qu'on a vu toutes les écritures
allemand alors là là ça a été alors là
j'ai vu mes parents pleurer de il avait
l'impression que paris n'était plus
paris quand nous sommes arrivés à hyper
ni je suis arrivé dans ma maison
il fait c'est tellement un bac maison et
mon mari m'a tout de suite dit il m'a
donné tout de suite mes responsabilités
il a dit c'est toi qui ira discuter avec
eux pour avoir la maison et ma foi c'est
moi qui était discuté avec l'officier
allemand qui voulait pas du tout ma voix
chez lui or je n'avais rien d'autre à
epernay que cette maison qu'on loue et
et il m'a amené dans le ja fait deux
pièces en bas un salon une salle à
manger
il m'a dit que c'était pas leurs troupes
que c'était truc de chaque
en tout cas il avait festoyé ils avaient
été malades
elle m'a dit jour ans deux pièces là est
une pièce pour la petite fille qui était
propre et des tout premiers la petite
fille est à nous et il l'a plus jamais
refusé et j'ai dit je vais nettoyer et
je veux j'ai accepté si bien que j'aie
cohabiter avec eux pendant sept mois je
crois je lis confinés dans leur chambre
j'avais dit dès le début j'ai mes
appartements
vous avez les veaux on va jamais les
hachez les
j'allais quand même à la fois est sévère
et digne mais être aimable
j'ai toujours été aimable et poli
alors très vite là leur sang sans se
donner absolument le modec les allemands
passent et on laisser tomber notre carte
du show absolument ridicule mais qui
montrait ce refus de l'occupation
quand nous sortir dehors et qu'il me
demandait d'aller admettons à la nation
les envoyer au château de vincennes
quand ils s'asseyaient dans le métro à
côté de nous on se levait ou alors on se
précipite et vous voyez des petites
choses ridicules et puis d'un lycée dès
qu'on pouvait en aller et mettre des v
sur leurs portes ou des croix de
lorraine mais n'arrivait pas à
comprendre que les français ne les
aiment pas parce que eux
à ce moment là était ce qu'on appelle
correct parce qu'on a dit qu'à ce moment
là mais c'est la vérité
il avait envoyé je pense lui repart et
des corps d'élite et tous ces gens
étaient se tenait piette est correct
mais nous nous étions parfaitement
incorrects
mais volontairement
[Musique]
quand travail famille patrie est arrivé
mon père à table nous a dit mais le
travail le travail en lui-même ne
signifie rien sur ses pas pourquoi on
travaille la famille il faut regarder
plus loin que son paillasson quant à la
patrie pétain l'a trahi il n'a rien à en
dire
ça a été fini on n'a plus jamais reparlé
d'abord sa voix c'est une voie de
vieillards geignarde et je trouvais ça
insupportable
c'est plus du tout pu écouter puis cette
manière de nous culpabiliser soyez sages
taisez vous c'est votre faute je
m'occupe de tout alors recettes c'était
insupportable pour moi bien sûr que la
zone libre n'était pas libre mais on
avait quand même des possibilités qui
n'ont pas eu un seul occupé on a pu se
regrouper commencé à se mettre d'accord
commencé à s'organiser
on parlait assez librement faisant
attention enfin on était pas on a
compris quand on a eu la gestapo plus
tard la milice quelle chance qu'on avait
eu les deux premières années
le mari chad et 1,7 pt avait dit que les
prises d'air ne reviendrais qu'on ne
dégagerait pas qu'il en allemagne au
rythme et y seraient rendus qui
rentreraient alors là on faisait signer
on s'était procuré des adresses des
femmes pour qui était plus dont le mari
était prisonnier de guerre et nous
avions donc nos amis qui est même avec
leur mari comme prisonnier de guerre
donc c'est un contact immédiat alors on
allait avec des premières pétitions
d'aller dans les dents des délégations
pour pour dire voilà on veut connaître
on veut savoir quand c'est que nos maris
vont revenir
c'était la promesse kabylité fait bon
cap ça ça n'était pas fait on a refait
des listes de pétitions pour connaître
les adresses des stalags qui en aide à
savoir au moins huit shows se trouve
maintenant tournons signait ça ça a été
très populaire
je disais que ça c'était presque une
chose que l'on faisait presque
ouvertement parce que c'était des fob
des femmes de prisonniers
ir et que tout était prêt à faire tout
ce qu'elle peut pour avoir des nouvelles
de leur mari j'étais rentré dans une
association ou qui regroupait des déjà
une femme donc il y avait une équipe qui
est aidée tout nous étions nous avions
perdu notre époque et on réfléchissait à
un double devoir de chrétien
il y avait deux dans cette situation et
j'ignore tout à fait ce que j'ai pu dire
mais je les dis d'une manière tellement
énergique
il est vrai que ça a été pour le point
de départ de mon engagement dans la
résistance non pas de bol engagement
moral et psychologique parce que ça je
vais lui dès l'invasion même
l'engagement pratique peu à peu quand il
n'y avait pas le dans ces manifestations
j'ai dit pour les prisonniers de guerre
disent pas ma pré cités pour le
ravitaillement
c'était pour le charbon c'était pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir aider des gens
parce que c'était vraiment dix c'était
une demi famille c'est le cas de dire
c'était terrible on a entraîné sur ces
buts là et quand on avait dix succès
parce qu'on a eu des succès dans les
mairies tenter les femmes allaient avec
laure gosse a dit tout seul et qu'on a
des en délégation qu'ils allaient en
délégation poser des problèmes on a eu
des distributions de charbon on a eu des
discussions de publi terre quand il y
avait un succès ça donne et c'est comme
ça que ça sert
est-ce que ça s'il agissait donc on a
reçu un grand une grande enveloppe dans
lequel il y avait beau être apte à ce
moment là c'était ce qu'avait dessus je
pourrais pas voulu dire on a reçu ça
avec simplement un papier un truc tapé à
la machine
recopier est distribuée et donc c'est ce
qu'on a fait même mon tout jeune frère
tout le monde recopier ça et pour mettez
ça dans des enveloppes on l'envoyait à
certaines personnes que l'on ça fait je
me suis rendu compte en contrebas du
trans bay tant ce genre de truc là
fallait tout le temps vigilant et la
vigilance est devenu une seconde nature
vous voyez dès ce moment là j'ai fait
très attention c'était au lycée
continuer à faire comme tout le monde
mais jamais personne jusqu'à ce qu'on
soit arrêté ne s'est rendu compte de ce
que je pouvais faire
et pourtant je m'étais aussi des tracts
dans les boîtes aux lettres des
professeurs et dans les puisqu'on avait
chacune des casiers dans les casiers des
élèves à qui je savais que ça pouvait
être utile 31 mai journée des maires
assurer le pain quotidien de vos enfants
ont du temps des produits de la terre
font de france aux français
assurer leur avenir heureux dans une
france libre et indépendante en boutant
les [__] hors du pays empêcher vos
maris fils et frère de produire pour la
machine de guerre allemande arbeit l'air
affameurs et à sa scène d'autres peuples
à bali traite française pétales havas
des compagnies qui ont enlevé notre
france à l'ennemi qui sauvegarder la vie
de vos enfants
rien ne sert de gémir il faut lutter
attend plus rien et est organisé les
nazis deadline nous prenez tout on
n'avait rien à manger
il y avait un million de prisonniers et
femmes étaient celles bon hiver il y
avait un désarroi généralisée nous les
jeunes nous ne pouvions pas supporter ça
et je parle pour nous mais je pense que
les
les autres les grands des adultes et et
ému par les mêmes sentiments et on
fabrique beaucoup plus le résistant par
une humiliation que par des choses
parfois beaucoup plus grande
je pouvais pas supporter les discours
dans lesquels ont visé mais nous sommes
vaincus enfin les bavardages aussi nous
sommes vaincus ou pas faire autrement
ce n'est pas possible de toute façon
rien n'est fait j'ai toujours des fous
qu'est-ce que tu n'étais on avait les
manu on avait pas d'armes on n'avait
rien du tout et on était simplement des
individus qui décidez de de tout faire
pour profiter
[Musique]
ici c'était donc les noms des premières
comité arrêté martha desrumaux danielle
casanova marie-claude vaillant-couturier
paul-portier marie dubois madeleine
marzin cetera et cetera
mais vous voyez des femmes comme ça il y
en avait beaucoup
il y en avait beaucoup qui faisait cela
comme surnaturel dead de solidarité et y
en a beaucoup qui ont perdu leur vie
avec ça c'était des résistantes et c'est
tout cet ensemble de résistants et de
résistante contre la résistance
[Musique]
et ces femmes qu'on envoie aux
lointaines bastille peuvent sauter
femmes témérité fille leur crime au
peuple c'est de savoir aimer
[Musique]